so I'm writing down a note to my phone
to last words to my family
um
Jeremy Renner breaks down in tears
detailing the aftermath of his
life-threatening snow plow accident I
really couldn't be more fortunate on
Wednesday Good Morning America shared a
new sneak peek from the actor's upcoming
sit down with Diane Sawyer where he
speaks candidly for the first time about
the near fatal January incident
someone's been
way right now listen to me you might
want to get a life flight out here
immediately Jeremy was run over by a
seven-ton snow plow on New Year's Day in
an attempt to save his nephew's life the
accident left him in critical condition
with 30 plus broken bones Jeremy also
had to undergo surgery for blunt chest
trauma and Orthopedic injuries and in
the clip we see Jeremy in a wheelchair
reflecting on how the whole thing might
have turned out had his nephew and
others not come to his rescue if I was
there on my own that had been a horrible
way to die
foreign
[Music]
surely
but
I wasn't alone it was my nephew
sweet Alex and
the rest of the calvary came and when
Diane starts talking about his time in
the hospital revealing he wrote A
Goodbye note to his family things take
an emotional turn
so I'm writing down a notes on my phone
to the last words to my my family
um
Jeremy Renner with us in a horrific
accident that he had the chance to chat
yeah no been in touch with him reached
out to me soon good I believe and oh
yeah all prayers are with him since the
accident Jeremy's friends and co-stars
have shared updates with E.T I taught
him yesterday yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's he's doing all right he's doing
he's doing well he's the best best guy
and you know
um he's awesome he is a force in nature
he's Unstoppable and I just am so
relieved that he's on the comeback Trail
and Jeremy he shared some updates too
that's the first shower
all right definitely a week or so
gross the actor posted that video with
his mom and sister just days after the
accident
seriously cool and you're totally doing
the walking motion crap yeah
um 40 of my weight and Jeremy shared
that clip from a recent physical therapy
session walking on an assisted treadmill
I've lost a lot of Flesh and bone in
this experience but I've been refueled
and refilled with love and titanium
Jeremy's interview airs April 6 on ABC
he encourages his fans to tune in to
hear the full story and thanks everyone
for all the positive loving prayers I
chose to survive you're gonna kill me no
wait Andy wraps it all up with a little
humor thank you will never be enough to
express my gratitude so I can offer up
some free snow cat rides up at the house
if you're interested
foreign